one hot October morning I got off the
all-night train in Mandalay the old
royal capital of Burma now Myanmar and
out on the street I ran into a group of
rough men standing beside their bicycle
rickshaws and one of them came up and
offered to show me around the price he
quoted who is outrageous it was less
than I would pay for a bar of chocolate
at home so I clambered into his treasure
and he began peddling us slowly between
palaces and pagodas and as he did he
told me how he had come to the city from
his village he'd earned a degree in
mathematics his dream was to be a
teacher but of course life is hard under
a military dictatorship and so for now
this was the only way he could make a
living many nights he told me he
actually slept in his trash or so he
could catch the first visitors off the
all-night train and very soon we found
that in certain ways we had so much in
common we were both in our 20s we were
both fascinated by foreign cultures but
he invited me home so we turned off the
wide crowded streets and we began
bumping down rough wild alleyways there
were broken shacks all around I really
lost a sense of where I was and I
realized that anything could happen to
me now I could get mugged or drugged or
something worse nobody would know
finally he stopped and led me into a hut
which consisted of just one tiny room
and then he leaned down and reached
under his bed and something in me froze
I waited to see what he would pull out
and finally he extracted a box inside it
was every single letter he had ever
received from visitors from abroad and
on some of them he had pasted little
black and white warn snapshots of his
new foreign friends so when we said
goodbye that night I realized he had
also shown me the secret point of travel
which is to take a plunge to go inwardly
as well as outwardly to places you'd
never go otherwise to venture into
uncertainty ambiguity even fear at home
it's dangerously easy to assume we're on
top of things out in the world you are
reminded every moment that you're not
and you can't get to the bottom of
things either everywhere people wish to
be settled Ralph Waldo Emerson reminded
us but only insofar as we are unsettled
is there any hope for us at this
conference we've been lucky enough to
hear some exhilarating new ideas and
discoveries and really about all the
ways in which knowledge is being pushed
excitingly forwards but at some point
knowledge gives out and that is the
moment when your life is truly decided
you fall in love you lose a friend the
lights go out and it's then when you're
lost or uneasy or carried out of
yourself that you find out who you are I
don't believe that ignorance is bliss
science has unquestionably made our
lives brighter and longer and healthier
and I'm forever grateful to the
teachers who showed me the laws of
physics and pointed out that three times
three makes nine I can count that out on
my fingers any time of night or day but
when a mathematician tells me that minus
3 times minus 3 makes 9 that's a kind of
logic that almost feels like trust the
opposite of knowledge in other words
isn't always ignorance it can be wonder
or mystery possibility and in my life I
found it's the things I don't know that
have lifted me up and pushed me forwards
much more than the things I do know it's
also the things I don't know that have
often brought me closer to everybody
around me for eight straight November's
recently I traveled every year across
Japan with the Dalai Lama and the one
thing he said every day that most seem
to give people reassurance and
confidence was I don't know what's going
to happen to Tibet when are we ever
going to get world peace what's the best
way to raise children frankly says this
very wise man I don't know the Nobel
Prize winning economist Daniel Kahneman
has spent more than 60 years now
researching human behavior and his
conclusion is that we are always much
more confident of what we think we know
than we should be
we have as he memorably puts it an
unlimited ability to ignore our
ignorance we know quotient erodes our
team is going to win this weekend and we
only remember that knowledge on the rare
occasions when we're right most of the
time were in the dark and that's where
real intimacy lies do you know what your
lover is going to do tomorrow
do you want to know the parents of us
all as some people call them Adam and
Eve could never die so long as they were
eating from the tree of life but the
minute they began nibbling from the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil they
fell from their innocence they grew
embarrassed and fretful self-conscious
and they learnt a little too late
perhaps that there are certainly some
things that we need to know that there
are many many more that are better left
unexplored now when I was a kid I knew
it all of course I had been spending 20
years in classrooms collecting facts and
I was actually in the information
business writing articles for Time
magazine and I took my first real trip
to Japan for two and a half weeks and I
came back with a 40 page essay
explaining every last detail about
Japan's temples its fashions its
baseball games its soul but underneath
all that something that I couldn't
understand so moved me for reasons I
couldn't explain to you yet that I
decided to go and live in Japan and now
that I've been there for 28 years I
really couldn't tell you very much at
all about my adopted home which is
wonderful because it means every day I'm
making some new discovery and in the
process looking around the corner and
seeing the hundred thousand things I'll
never know
knowledge is a priceless gift but the
illusion of knowledge can be more
dangerous than ignorance thinking that
you know your lover or your enemy can be
more treacherous than acknowledging
you'll never know them every morning in
Japan as the Sun is flooding into our
little apartment I take great pains not
to consult the weather forecast because
if I do
my mind will be over-clouded distracted
even when the day is bright
I've been a full-time writer now for 34
years and the one thing that I have
learnt is that transformation comes when
I'm not in charge when I don't know
what's coming next when I can't assume I
am bigger than everything around me and
the same is true in love or in moments
of crisis suddenly we're back in that
trash or again and we're bumping off the
broad well-lit streets and we're
reminded of the really the first law of
travel and therefore of life you're only
as strong as your readiness to surrender
in the end perhaps being human is much
more important than being fully in the
know thank